let me pull up this story from yahoo
news
hillary clinton promotes but her emails
merch after fbi search of trump's
mar-a-lago
so her her fundraiser pitch is i did
something way worse
got away with it and now you're gonna
give me money oh my god the day after
his house got raided literally
what is happening
and she has that like um photoshop
picture of her looking like a younger
picture of her with her huge all that
work done on those cheekbones like
hey look look look i don't i don't i
don't care about the merch stuff
trump has dropped targeted merch he's
he's also made fun of democrats in a
similar way we really are seeing the
left try to learn from how the right did
meme warfare with like the dark brandon
do you see this they made a nazi meme of
of joe biden and then they unironically
posted it and people were like what are
you doing like that was made to make fun
of joe biden why are you posting do you
have that image available nazi meme
dark brandon rises and then go to images
wasn't there a thought that this was a
was it you and i'm sorry about this yeah
there was like this was like a chinese
app type deal yeah i wasn't able to
confirm this i saw something on twitter
i know everything i was super curious
yeah i really want to look into that so
so we have it right here this is the
eagle
so this is a mockery of the dark knight
rises where there's a bat
in the in like there's a skyscraper and
he's looking down and there's like a bat
in the buildings and so they did this
eagle which many people pointed out is
very similar to the the nazi eagle and
he looks like vladimir lenin in that
picture yeah what's going on
you know
hey maybe you guys when people make
memes to make fun of joe biden and then
you just take them and repost them you
should probably look into what you're
doing yeah yeah was this supposed to be
endearing they're just illiterate to the
internet this is like in your face like
if it does if history looks back and
like this is when the united states went
full like totalitarian and then you see
that image and they're like oh they just
blatantly told everyone he was doing
gonna do it yeah well i mean but like
joe biden doesn't even know this meme
exists yeah joe you see the video of him
trying to shake chuck schumer's hand
twice oh my gosh that was weird and the
jacket just held it there yeah well no
he shakes so he's a chuck chuck schumer
talks turns around shakes biden's hand
body puts his hand down and then looks
and then pulls his hand out again and he
stares at him and then like puts it to
his face
i can't imagine living in the fever
dream that life experiences on a daily
basis they're like bringing bts into the
white house and he's like hi
who are you and they don't speak any
english this what's bts
k-pop oh okay what is what does bts mean
it's a good question bangtan don yeah i
don't know behind the scenes
i thought it was i heard behind the
scenes or something like that no idea no
bangtan boys you're right though on the
fundraising piece do you um do you
remember last year when there was that
video that came out attacking desantis
because they didn't want him to
get credit for how awesome florida's
doing so they basically tried to
showcase that florida's this terrible
place full of freedom and it was like
this lovely video of all these people
smiling and laughing and they're like
they don't take mass seriously and it's
this family walking on the beach so
happy it's like yeah you guys don't
realize but you keep shooting yourself
in the foot when you try to do stuff
like this yeah yeah yeah
trump's done similar things and and
trump supporters have done similar
things in terms of making targeted merch
but my point on the whole thing is like
coming out and being like we got away
with it not give us money it's kind of
like uh you know
people are already worried about a
double standard and an imbalance in the
justice system
cackling while you raise money off of it
is probably not going to help this
country no
but you know the funny thing is many of
these democrats think donald trump is
the one who's committing all the crimes
because they don't read the news
dude what is up with
people are obsessed with the cult like
it's but what i mean is the cult worship
of the humans like this politic i'm all
about politics and understanding the way
government works and
how many people you need to hire to be
in the republic and to facilitate the
transfer of power but like when you get
obsessed about the individuals and
you're like well joe biden if you some
people talk about joe biden then another
person's like yeah but trump like that
has nothing to do with what i'm talking
about right now i don't uh like let's
focus on and
it's like it's a video game or like a
movie and they're talking about their
favorite characters or the villains they
hate like
it so it seems so detached from reality
of like you better get enough food for
your kids like or for yourself we got to
really focus on making sure well we we
reach our basic necessities
yeah the the people who live in cities
for the most part have no idea no when
it comes to basic necessities no i was
arguing with a guy in fa on on twitter
once it was really funny was a yang
supporter
and uh like i was i was a big fan of
yang early on i think he's done things i
don't agree with but he he's alright
he's you know whatever i love him but he
uh he was talking about ubi and i was
like i agree with like he's created this
huge extensive policy list he's really
thought about i respect that but ubi
makes no sense
i asked some guy we were arguing and i
can't remember exactly what the context
was why we brought it up but i mentioned
like
eventually there's not going to be food
in supermarkets or eventually people
won't be able to source things like milk
if there's no one who's you know who's
doing base level jobs or we have to
create a surf class and he's like what
do you mean the milk's at the store
and then i was like
i was like yeah but like the milk won't
come
from the production to the store so
people can't get it he's like what are
you talking about people just go to the
store to get milk and then i was like
the store won't have milk when the
people that bottle it don't sell it to
them and he's like i don't know what
you're trying to say and i'm like whoa
oh my gosh did you guys see the video
last week of the girl that's the farmer
who was showcasing the bale of hay in
her trunk did you guys know
and she was talking about how much the
price has skyrocketed of her hay that
she has to get to feed her cattle that
then produce the milk and the meat um
and so she talks about how her hay is
like quadrupled in the last 12 months
and her warning to everyone is this will
be passed on to you this fall of course
like if you think that this is isolated
wait till it hits the shopping centers
and you see your price of beef and of
milk skyrocket because to feed these
animals is becoming so incredibly
expensive even chickens yeah even
chicken here's the other thing people
need to understand too we give our we
give these animals corn now there are a
lot of farms you come out here yeah and
we see the cows eating grass all day you
got the chickens they're eating feed
they're in layer but they're eating bugs
but in a lot of places it's it's just
corn the factory farmed salmon corn
yeah subsidized yeah really gross i need
to reclaim my name's heritage i don't
know if this is true but i heard that
tilapia are fed in farms uh underneath
these cages um
or like
wire platforms that chickens are above
them and like
crap into crap into the water and then
the tilapia eat it
and that's like how they feed the
tilapia i don't think it's possible that
goes into grocery stores i hope not i
don't think that's possible because the
chicken chickens have one hole a cloaca
yeah and there's like there's
like a hen has three things they have
like where the egg comes from and they
have like the poop and the peep and it
mixes together yeah so you've got yuri
poisoned the waters yeah and they
couldn't do it yeah the water would just
become i hope it's not true i don't want
it to be true i remember working in the
restaurant industry for like 15 years
you know up until about five or six
years ago and they uh they would talk a
lot about farm
farmed uh tilapia was way nasty it was
like one of the nastiest fish you could
ever order from a restaurant is farm you
want wild tilapia if you're ever gonna
get tilapia i don't know why though and
maybe it has something to do with that
maybe not you know what i'd prefer to
believe you know people who believe in
these big conspiracies you know like i
don't think there's a grand global cabal
i think there are powerful interests
vying for power and colluding behind the
scenes so the epstein stuff like well i
mean
maxwell was convicted like we know they
were doing this stuff and we know they
were they were connected with powerful
individuals maybe it was blackmail or
whatever but they clearly didn't have
full control because epstein is no
longer alive and maxwell is locked up so
it wasn't you know
i don't think that there's one like
illuminati or something like that i just
think powerpoint just do this stuff i'd
prefer to believe that aliens controlled
everything it's if i'm gonna believe
something
you know as grandiose i'm gonna i'm
gonna shoot for the stars they do
literally and assume it's alien some
people call them god other people call
them aliens some people call it
interesting dimensional being yes
so when you mentioned jfk saying there's
like a greater force at play we're all
imagining there's like some military
industrial complex but it's actually a
fifth dimensional dmt l for something
you know a demon from the from beyond
the veil joe rogan would fall out of his
chair
yeah right yeah i it's more fun to
believe in in that stuff yeah more fun
yeah well definitely true spirit war is
no joke were you gonna say well no i was
just i was gonna say absolutely i'm a
big believer you know i'm a person of
faith i believe that a lot of this is
spiritual warfare and it's interesting
to see the people who have realized that
over the past few years i heard tucker
carlson speak of all people and he was
speaking actually at a church that i go
to in san diego and this guy's on stage
tucker carlson largest talk show this
was like three months ago largest talk
show host in the world and this guy
looks at this audience and says i am
thinking i'm insane in real time for
even saying this because i two years ago
never would have believed myself if i
said what i'm about to say everything
that we're seeing is there's something
deeper going on there's something
spiritual i'm not sure what it is but
there's some deeper war at play here
because this doesn't make sense anymore
like all the basic fabrics of a fabric
of humanity is being ripped up things
related to our identity who are men who
are women like basic things that we just
accepted as truth for thousands of years
now people are attacking and so he
basically said i have come to believe
that this is far greater than politics
this is way deeper and so i do think
there's like a cultural shift happening
when we're all realizing that this goes
a lot deeper than just party politics
it's not like a gop versus dem thing
there's a much deeper thing going on
even in the political world there's a
uniparty we clearly understand that now
and that unit party often acts in the um
antithesis of the interests of average
americans and you look at these things
and you're like there's something deeper
happening here that's controlling you
because this isn't
this is so different than anything we've
ever seen before well as a christian i'm
sure you believe that the spiritual
warfare aspect of it isn't new and
that's always been the case throughout
human history but why do you think it's
it seems to be
getting more intense more noticeable
in our daily lives that's i think that's
it it's that it's more blatant it's more
out in the open and there was a time
like an invitation for us to somehow
participate uh my personal belief is yes
my personal belief is that any time that
you're confronted with evil it's your
duty to stand against it right right so
uh revel is it revelation or revelation
yes revelation yeah revelation
revelation end of days yep and now
what's going on a lot of people have
different views in terms of where we're
at in history i have no idea but i will
say that there is a very clear message
communicated through the scriptures that
as time goes on things will become more
blatant in fact there's a scripture that
talks about how in the last days
everything's going to be uprooted
related to identity people exchange
truth for lies and they'll listen to
things that'll make their ears tickle
and deny reality and so it's like who
knows but that seems like a lot also it
will come in like a thief of in the
night
therefore yeah you really can't know the
day or the hour yeah
both of you are christian
so uh my question i suppose is
um is it preferable that we are in the
end of days and something is culminating
as to your faith or would it be
preferable that
life was just simple and normal and you
were farming corn with a smile on your
face great question i think you can have
both life is simple and you can have
normalcy but also
uh
not not be excited for the end times but
have hope
you know
and not be so pr prideful as to think
you know what the timing is because i i
think about this in a
like a more secular context but also a
religious context and i'm imagining you
know are there people who are excited
for
revelation for the end of days for the
second coming for the rapture or
whatever might be happening
and if and if if you separate the faith
element from that are there people who
think
in reality we could choose to be happy
live in a living on a farm and have pigs
and chickens and food
but many of these people
would prefer the chaos and the violence
because they believe at the end of that
violence is the utopia yeah the good
news there are a lot of people who
i think at least who want to make things
worse as quickly and as intensely as
possible
so that it culminates in something
and i don't know what that will be
accelerationism yeah but i think you
know the bible's pretty clear about this
like there's the apostle paul that says
that we should pray for peaceful and
quiet lives and yet his also message and
it's not a contradictory one but his
tethered messages and also prepare for
what's coming yes so there's this
tethered reality of like pray for peace
and quiet and do whatever you can to
make that happen
also you need to be prepared yes because
there will be a reality the world is
delving into chaos and you want to be
ready when that comes and so i think
it's that dichotomy a very literal
example that is that every 20 30 40 000
years we get hit by comets and
everything gets wiped to zero and like
that's been happening over the last
hundreds of thousands of years in the
geological records of cometary impact so
like
yeah you want to live in peace and love
your whatever the last record of that
well i know 12 800 years ago at the end
of the younger driest comet shattered
over north america and peppered the
glacial continent melted all the ice and
just caused a global flood wiped out all
the megafauna in north america flattened
the united states which is why we have
these planes yeah maybe that's the great
flood yeah then no it was uh
a couple few thousand years later there
was another flood which they think was
noah's flood like six thousand years ago
that mythology goes across cultures
every culture has like a flood right or
something like that you have a great
flood story geez but you are spot on
like there are these things that will
come that there's no ability to control
and no matter how powerful the cabal or
multiple cabals are like even they will
be taken off guard yeah i think when you
were asking that question earlier about
why does it seem like it's all coming to
a head right now the spiritual war i
find that it's always is but now because
of the introduction of psychedelics into
the mainstream the proliferation of the
knowledge through the internet people
are sensing it i can feel it i was like
a logic if i can't see it and prove it i
don't believe it that was me until i was
23 years old now i feel energy i see
patterns because of thc and the
marijuana um psilocybin i just when you
start to see the difference between life
and non-life very starkly and and i mean
and you start to practice reiki and
things like that or reiki i'm not sure
how to pronounce it is that a good thing
i think it's necessary to understand
what's happening thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there